dans le cirque de mafate avec ses 90
âmes horaire est un il est qu'ils se
développent un peu d'élevage beaucoup de
cultures trois gîtes et autant de
groupes de musique les activités ne
manquent pas est ce pour cela qu'il
porte ce nom
ça vient peut-être de zorro
s'appellerait enfin c'est ça veut dire
bonne terre en malgache mont avila tale
est pas mauvaise monsieur le marchand
qui est monté un jour poursuivant un
cabri on va découvrir un guide un
esclave quitter la nes claque six
échappés a marre on lui a demandé on est
d'où il a dit blessé aurait oreja ici
en 1781 nicolas lemarchand chassant le
cabri marron en compagnie de son cousin
et de quelques amis découvrent un il est
oui alors un noir marron il a déjà
baptisé se replacent oreja bonne terre
en dialecte malgache
séduit par ce bon point le marchand on
obtient la concession qui devient
horaire avec info avant de se
transformer en horaire a eu dans les
registres
la famille le marchand mais ce nouvel il
est en culture et récolte bientôt du
maïs du café et des fruits elle y
acclimate notamment plusieurs arbres
fruitiers d'europe dont l'olivier
l'abricotier le prunier l'amandier et
d'autres de la même famille elle y
développe également l'élevage
mais des démêlés avec le fisc finissent
pas ruiner la famille
lille est se rendort jusqu'à la fin du
19e siècle
l'arrivée de colons de salazie relance
alors la culture du géranium et des
grains et lille est reprend vie
mais la mévente du géranium et le
cyclone de 1948 dévastent les
plantations et ruina nouveau lille est
à la création de la coopérative en 1956
il ne reste plus qu'un seul forestier
sur place depuis 1978 grâce à la
construction de la canalisation
augustave une vingtaine de familles
s'est réinstallé sur le plateau
d'horaires